So yeah, like, I I I feel like I've been living, I mean I don't know if you guys recall this, remember
when my uh transformer went out? Yeah, and I I said, like, because the car accident and other stuff that
I've been living in this just like that clenched full body clench and that's that's how I've been
for the last week and uh relating to this, like, I sat down to read Heidegger last night and it was
very difficult. It was very difficult to just read it and by the way as you guys know this isn't hard
Heidegger, no, this is this is like Heidegger at his easiest and kindness and gentleness and and I
just found and I it's just something I realized in terms of myself, like, I need certain types of
conditions to be in place in order to be able to to to think with someone. I mean it was really the
effect of it was therapeutic and it was great. It just was not pleasant. I mean initially my initial
encounter it's like I just found myself reading and obviously it relates to the content of what
he's talking about. I found myself reading it's like what's the point? What's the point? Like I want the
point and I wanted it fast and I and you know Heidegger if nothing else does not write fast
right he writes meticulously. Yeah, that's right, you would not want to be stuck in a car with him
because you would never get off the scene and grow up. Right, exactly. Um, but there's something really
great to that in the effect after really I'm not joking like 20 minutes of kind of painful
forcing myself to read the sentences over and over and over again because I was not extracting the
message and not you know um, it slowed me down and it was good. It was it was effective and I think that
the sort of larger point for me is that this is like, you know, that there is a mode of reading he
talks about as a tone of that set, you know, hearing different tones but there's a practice of reading
that I understand why someone gets for us why you know for instance newcomers to this type of
thinking get frustrated because it's frustrating. It doesn't work the same way and you have to be in
the mindset to be open to be to it being a kind of therapeutic conceptual thinking practice, right, to in
order to say like okay I'm gonna sit with this and I'm gonna you know because like I said I really was
rereading sentences and these are not hard sentences but I was rereading them multiple times because I'm
like I'm not in I'm not attending to this I am just trying to like quickly get it and it took a good 20
minutes and but I will say when I kind of got into the reading of it I felt calmer, right, I I I and
everything kind of went more smoothly after that, right, so I mean thinking of reading philosophy as a
kind of mental therapeutics, right, like is I think a really good way. I mean the last time when we talked
about this when the a year ago about the transformer thing I remember it was Nietzsche for me that I was
turning to but that's a really different like Nietzsche doesn't give me slowness in the way that Heidegger
gives me slowness. Yeah, and I I needed that given the anger of the stupidity of the administrations
dealing with the covet situation. Yeah, which by the way let's keep this in because like this is this is
shocking. I mean to me it really is just shocking the level of it's either stupidity or stubbornness
and I I'm sure some combination of the two but I I can't I I kind of can't get over how I can't get
over it, like when am I going to stop being surprised at the craven stupidity of people in positions of
authority like university administrators in in this particular case, but it's not only that we could
talk about the state house and the legislation our attorney general and all that sort of shit going on
and and to me it's like this is why I need to talk about Heidegger or this is one of the one of the
sources is because this is a it is it's therapeutic. This is a way of slowing down thinking and attention
in a way that frankly just feels better, right, like it just feels better and he and he encourages it
both stylistically and you know in terms of the content if you want to tell you know um, I I do feel
like I mean if we want to turn to it explicitly like I feel like um, there's a confidence to the the
writing stylistically syntactically that's almost comforting because it's like it feels like Heidegger
at his best even though it's it's not as most complex necessarily or it's not as most confusing
he feels very assured in the kind of moves some of them are polemical some of you some of the points
you could obviously challenge but it's like he is going to keep and it feels fluid too like you can
follow the train of thinking I don't know it's very like grandfatherly right where you're not sure
where he's taking you but you feel comforted and part of it is you know there's the there's the
simultaneous like comfort of it seems like this guy knows what's going on he's been down this path
before but also he's in the act of doing the thinking with you so he's both with you and leading
You at the same time, yeah, I, I really like that analogy because it also explains the couple times
where it's like the grandfather makes the racist comment but you just kind of let it go and roll
your eyes and he did, yeah, and allow him to continue with the story and you're like, well, that's just what
the grandfather does for me. That's his language of essence, authenticity, yeah, right, like so, but, but it
didn't, I mean, remember the last time that we talked about it? Like, I was just so hung up on the piety
you know, and, and, but for whatever reason this time in reading it I still saw it, I still noted it, but I
allowed it. I was like, okay, whatever, and, um, and, you know, again, there are other stages that one can get
which is rethinking the notions of essence and authenticity. There are other, as we talked about, but
but for you know in this case it is the grandfather analogy. It's like, oh yeah, okay, that's his, that's
grandfather's racism and you just let it go because that's not the point of the story, right? The story
is something else and it's just going to ruin everything if you, you know, force him to confront
that. I mean, it is. It's a recurring theme and refrain, the kind of call to or a plea for an authentic
relation to the world or to being and of course it's easily challengeable but I, I think you're
right, like it doesn't help you to read Heidegger in that way, like to chastise him every time
every time he mentions that, you know, I mean you can think about it like not every, you know, a lot of
films, a lot of art have weird conservative kind of through lines, like not every great piece of art
is thoroughly progressive. Nothing, right? Right? If it is then it would be not progressive, like if every
component of it fit the mold exactly. Yeah, but so I, uh, because again I only read three and four and
the language of, well, he didn't use the language of authenticity in one or two, right? But he still
mobilized it in the sense of implicit, the handicraft stuff. But even that receded for me in three and
four, like authenticity wasn't really much of a of a part of it. The essence was, but I've now, you know,
we had talked several episodes past when you know to lose uses the language of transcendence, it's like
I can no longer think of transcendence in that more traditional sense, right? When I hear I'm to the
point with Heidegger when he talks about essence I can't hear it in that more traditional sense anymore.
I still have a hard time with authenticity. I still have a hard time, like, you know, with, with the
privileging, but I just didn't see that happening at least in in lectures three and four. Well, one, I mean
so if we're going back to three and four there are a couple places where I have oof, right, these are this
is my eye rolling at the grandfather, uh, like the essence and the essential origin of the manner of
knowing, you know, the those types of words are, you know, this doesn't lead to that, um, and I, I think part
of what's behind the eye rolling for me is there is the sense that it's just unnecessary, right? Like he
doesn't need in this thing he doesn't need to make the claim that he's after something that's more
essential than when someone else is. He can, he could simply be after something that's a different turn
on it that enables a different orientation or a different attitude in his terminology, right? Like
he doesn't need for to claim that he's after the essence of knowing even, and, and I get your point
Nathaniel which is you don't hear essence in in the same way I still hear it in that way like I still
hear I've I've got the real one or I have a sense of what the real one quote unquote is because of course
it isn't it is the sort of projecting and receding
I mean look it's a question of an instrumental relationship to communication because in those
words, and Derrida does stuff with this with like 9/11, right? Like this sort of compacting of a whole
dispersed series of, um, phenomena and actions into a nominal, like an incredibly short form that we can
all, we all act as if, oh, the you or oh, you know, covid, like we know what we're talking about there
um, so so that I mean I get the critique and I think that he's right like I mean that makes sense to me
because when one of the things that shortening of words indicates is that is that sort of all I'm
interested in is the shortest way possible to communicate an idea to you and and I'm not sort of
thinking through that idea at all that's why I'm shortening it I mean that's the basis
for the capacity the ability to shorten it requires a whole lot of background infrastructure that you're
assuming in common so that that shortened word is now a technical attribution rather than a site to
think through yeah but but the flip side is and this is you know one of the bristling places for me the
flip side is that's true for every word yeah, right, like yeah, that that's what a word does and so and
and in all fairness he is going to go after what words do, right, like that's not it's not like he's
Going to miss that point, but that's one of the one of the functions of language is precisely this
kind of sense of encapsulation, concretization, or freezing of, you know, freeze framing of a heterogeneous
massive phenomenon and for somebody like Hegel, you know, in his articulation of the understanding or
of any of those apparatuses that's the primary function of language of sense perception is the
reduction of complexity for use for mobilization, application and for Heidegger and for Nietzsche that
apparatus if you want to call that kind of as a like an emblem for the entire Hegelian system or for
humanism for whatever for anthropomorphic thinking that's the target, right? I mean, for Heidegger for
Nietzsche maybe even for Deleuze to some extent, right? I mean, it's not just that they're after it's not
that they're it's not that Heidegger wants to access complexity that is being uh sort of forestalled or
masked by language or by the faculty of the understanding is that he wants to, it seems like
foster some sort of more ethically attuned relation to the world, to your own relating to the world, how
do you relate those would be this I think those would be the same thing I mean I don't I I would so
the the attentiveness to it depends on what we mean by complexity, yeah, right? Like but uh if what complexity
means is just there are more parts then you're right it's not simply complexity um but yeah I I agree with
you his interest is in is in encouraging or fostering an attitude, right, or disposition or you know my
terminology I mean that's one of the things that came across there were a couple of points in there
where it's just like when he talks about the tone of the sentence like this is what I'm calling style
you know um and he talks consistently about you know like the way of the thinking of the lectures
being more important than any particular point that he's making right and I'm like yeah I I get that and
I get that there is a there is an attempt to encourage a different kind of disposition not
unrelated to how we started the conversation of like look when I went into this I was very frustrated
because I couldn't pull out you know the the sort of chunk you know the bumper sticker version checks
chunks and it took me a long time to get into the headspace to read with him right you know and and
when I did read with him one of the things that I lost one of the things that sort of fell to the
wayside was a desire to criticize to critique to disagree to say oh well hold on a second you know
that just because I was following something right I was riding the way I mean sorry I've been out on the
water but or even a desire even a desire to simplify not even to critique but to provide a summary or a
glossary because he even mentions that of like everybody wants to do that with Nietzsche provide
a glossary of terms of concepts a summary of the system so that it's more uh you know amenable or
digestible usable right and it's like that's not the point of the thinking the point is to follow the
thinking somehow and interpret this it is the velocity that you know his part of the the problem with
the velocity of this technological nominalization that he has with is it speed it doesn't speed
just hypostasize but it's it's a speed hypostasizing right where you can move from one hypostasized point
to the next quick quick quick and he wants to get in and unravel them and follow them and figure out
you know what their inclinations are and so he's very much so like instituting a
stylistic velocity that you you have brought up Derrida and Deleuze and others and I I read
Deleuze to be faster in in some ways where you know rather than sitting and unraveling a concept which
I would say Derrida does as well I would say Derrida is very slow in that way um Deleuze as putting
concepts in relationship to each other and still very meticulously right you know speed doesn't have to
be sloppy but meticulously experimenting with what those alliances do the terminology here is much more
narrow or it's much you know Deleuze will pull stuff from a thousand different area arenas fields
and kind of uh make some sort of collage Heidegger seems to use like five words total you know and
just keep like meditating on them that's the beauty of the German language you can just put put those
five together five together in a series of different combinations and you have a book called Being and
Time right but I I agree and so that's where that's where the sense of the speed I agree that speed is
quite important but speed has it's not simply about fast and slow that there is something qualitative in
speed that that matters here as well so that Deleuze's fastness in that regard um it's a it's a tonal
it's a tonal difference from Derrida's slowness or Heidegger's um slowness and yet they're invested
doing similar kinds of interruptions right um and so that's where I go like okay it's not simply a
question of fast bad slow good and I think Heidegger does sort of lean towards fast bad slow good I don't
think that Derrida does, like, I think that Derrida, you know, like that that sort of the what I, the
therapeutic style what I use it for to read is is a little more complicated and post Heidegger I think
it it does come to their relation to authenticity or to that concept though yeah I agree Heidegger's
slowness is actively pushing against the speed of technology and for someone like Deleuze he's not
interested in stripping away from modernity or something like that right he's interested in
experimenting with the conditions that we have Heidegger does he has an interesting way of dealing
with it in a few moments in these series he doesn't simply want to like go back to the Greek age like
the the the nostalgia is like kind of more strangely articulated where he basically wants to to force your
way out of the inauthentic relation like where you have to push through it through the last man
into the overman like it's a very it's a concerted like sort of like trembling effort you know to see
that's where I that's where I think I mean I you know this is Derrida's line on Heidegger uh you know
and it just makes sense to me that Heidegger sees Nietzsche as the last metaphysician because he
foresaw the end of metaphysics and Derrida's like well that makes Heidegger the last metaphysician
right um and I do I do sense that because I at least in terms of the Nietzsche that I read which
obviously goes through Derrida and Deleuze you know it can't not but that's not like Nietzsche
is not that simple right like or it's it's or that's that's a version of Nietzsche that
you know worked in the early or the mid-20th century but I don't I don't think is is that
interesting anymore um but it does seem like that's Heidegger's I mean I agree with you that
there is a kind of and he he will do a lot to massage this but a kind of critique of of modernity
yeah um yeah that's that's the baseline here I don't get that in I don't get that in Deleuze I
don't get that in Derrida um you know I mean you do get the sense that they every philosopher
kind of says that things are bad but the the approach to those things like Heidegger he he
he does like you're saying he massages that point but I find it to be similar to because he he says it
can turn into a platitude the the wasteland grows can just turn into an empty platitude and everybody
can hang on to that because there's data you know people are people are dying you know that technology
is uh alienating us and at a certain point everybody has access to that opinion but Heidegger also says
that so it's like you it's hard to distance him from that platitudinal but you won't have but you
also won't have Heidegger saying things like what Deleuze does in the rhizome chapter of like write slogans
right yeah you're not gonna see that he's he's he's not gonna go there I mean it's still again and I I like
this I mean for me it's it's kind of simple like this is one flavor uh of thinking and it really is
functional and important and and and I really you know I have a kind of admiration fascination
compulsion towards it but it's one you know it it's not or or it's seven I'm but it's not everything
right and it's not a telos you know it's to me it's a I have a much more pragmatic relation which is
Heidegger when I'm angry you know Nietzsche when I'm sad right like yeah you know the these are
the things that hook me it's like a mood playlist on Spotify right that's what it is it's a Spotify
mood playlist of philosophy yeah I mean that it's that's a little bit too reductive but it's not
terribly so I mean it's bad to think of it simply in terms of emotion but think of it in terms of like
you know how my thinking is moving reading this does a certain kind of thing reading that like I didn't
want to read Nietzsche last night like because if anything Nietzsche just gets me more amped up and I
didn't need that I'm going to be less amped up you know I mean or it's just reveals the the reductive
way in which we tend to think about emotions as yeah just the the feeling the quality of experience of
being in this or that state and you know taking on a bit more of a robust orientation to is like
you know anger isn't just how I feel anger is a modality of relationship to myself oneself and
everything else that shut down some kind of modes like ways of becoming and and opens up others
right I'm not sure at least for me I'm not sure that my particular organism it opens up very much at
all like it's it's just it feels like that is the the equivalent of the neurotic loop where I just
cannot I am just cycling through you know on the way paddling back like I had sort of sworn to myself
that I wasn't going to think about the situation at South Carolina today like because there's nothing
I can do today and I just found myself unwillingly just do it playing the conversations and playing
you know rephrasing and in my head and I'm trying like I even turned like turned on my Marcus Aurelius
audiobooks like you know just trying to produce a different it just didn't work save me marcus
well it's not I mean that's just what I have on the audiobooks you know um but and it just doesn't
work but it's it is a kind of I mean that really is why I'm writing about style but I mean it's just
this sort of cultivating a kind of rhythm of my thinking that's more um healthy I mean I I don't for
lack of a better word it's just it just becomes for me that neurotic loop of anger becomes right
not not generative and just relentlessly like this is it's resentment and I I see it in myself I know
it in myself I recognize it and it's bad for this version of the organism yeah but I mean that's you
know Heidegger Deleuze everybody has some version of like thought thinks you or languages that all that
stuff where it's like you you don't have full authority over the over the movement of your
thinking so in some ways I mean I I don't know how because obviously that dispositionally or affectively
that sucks to be in that zone but like for someone like Heidegger I mean what would Heidegger's therapy
session if you're on the couch with Heidegger what what do you think he would tell you probably
just to just to just to move through it you know like I don't think he would have some like answer
there because he he understands and he says it again and again and Hegel does and everybody that
you are guided by presuppositions which you know so the unconscious in some ways is the director
I feel like the overman would be at least the way it's articulated here could be a useful way of
thinking that charge because it's you know I mean the the way we talked about it in your class a while
ago John is that of course it's not a person it's not Jeff Bezos which is kind of what Heidegger says
here the overman is not Jeffrey Bezos it is not it is not Elon Musk it is not Jeffrey Bezos it is
not a politician it is not a superhero it is a basically a state of potential or it's something
on the horizon that I guess you can aspire to or it might be out one of the interesting things that
Heidegger said was that he might be out there but you're never going to locate him right there are
instances of it right in lots of places right but it's it's a it's a name for an aspiration for change
basically you know of overcoming human constraints uh which is one way of dealing with the the political
ethical charges of our current predicament so you I mean you could you could make the overman the the
figure for for somehow overcoming our post-modern predicament the the the coronavirus situation you
know how would the how would the overman respond to USC's fucked up uh you know response to the delta
variant the overman ain't fucking teaching modern rhetorical theory in there probably not probably not
he's living in a cave somewhere talking with his eagle yeah talking with his well that's the
Zarathustra that's Zarathustra because I do oftentimes think that the over the overman in terms of the
figure is just a common I mean it's just like it's it's any it's it's a dimension of futurity that's
constitutive of like anybody right like it's it's not uh it's not a person it's not a goal even
Heidegger thinks of it in terms of more goal like than right yeah than I would have thought yeah
the the overman can only be giving birth to right well and then yeah that's that's the to me that's
the crucial part for nature is there's no it's just give birth to the overman it's not be the
well and then Heidegger it's like there's just one sentence but it's like the overman comes into
being as soon as he dies so it's like it's generation it's generativity is when it passes
away which is just right like yeah like give birth to it because the second it's given it can't be
right it can only become right I mean it is sort of like that figure of as John said futurity or
or like the change into but what so would the would the overman like because you guys have talked about
this in relation to Deleuze's thinking like that kind of zone you get in when you're or flow flow state
when you're able to kind of channel your thinking and writing in a productive way and you can
effectively feel it would that be like in in Heidegger's terms here would that be somehow channeling
that energy this sounds now very like mystical the way I'm putting it but I don't know I mean I
you know I just and I know that this doesn't answer your question it's just shifting it but I always
think of the importance of the concept of the overman is the call for the overman not the overman right
you know um and which is not to say that the overman even as a call doesn't have attributes but
those aren't the important dimensions of it um or maybe the attributes are so um um vague as to be
determinable in whatever form every call takes right that the you know that might be it's like uh
the messianic without messianism right the Derrida takes from Benjamin and that's sort of how I I think
of it um but that doesn't really answer that doesn't answer your question like it can do all kinds of
work um depending on the circumstance i mean i guess there might be an interesting location to think that
question because you know when you're talking about the zone or the flow or whatever you know i tend to
talk about that in terms of kairos and especially sort of like embodied senses of kairos and like being
in the zone playing a basketball game or you know whatever or in the zone of writing or whatever else
it is and you know it is an interesting question to ask like does the the figure of the overman play or
does it complicate that picture that we've given you know so frequently where you know to be in the
zone and in the game is in some ways to be taken by the game the division between me and the game has
been rendered meaningless and you know my my play in the game is part of simply like the its own
futurity its own its own becoming so i mean is there sort of like a point of
conflation of you know like the kairotic moment as it you know merges with the overman this i mean
the figure of the overman maybe my problem is that i i want to kind of concretize the concept and the
point of the concept is precisely not to be put into simplified terms it's not a state of being
you know but that's a but that's okay because i think there's nothing else you can do other than
that and i don't think that there's anything wrong with that i just we have we what we'd have to do
something with kairos and with the game to take it away just like we have to do this with the things
that i was saying earlier about anger and whenever to take it away from a simply individualized
experience right you know um and to think of it as a sort of social social force um but but yeah why
not i mean why not envision over manness as being this sort of dimension of again the hard thing has
to there has to be a component of overcoming of what is there has to be right like so it can't simply
be and this is a lot of times the way of thinking of being in the zone is like i am so fully connected
to what is even even though i'm subverting i mean i'm unconscious right that's the expression
with basketball he was unconscious um even though it's subverting consciousness it's still like i am
so in tune with what is um and so it can't be what what could a game what could it mean to be
there is in a game which is so fully flowed right it's it's constantly moving and changing but also
within the dimensions of a game you know within a sort of confined game so so i don't know i mean i see
something to the experience of the being in the zone that matters i have often thought of it in
terms of kairos but i haven't really connected that with the overman but give it a shot man i mean
if if that interests you why not right like in recognizing the perils of course of like i don't want to
make this simply a present entity even as an experience but nevertheless this is a way of thinking
of it that seems viable well i mean like look i'm not committed to i was just throwing it out there
as a possibility but you know we can think think about basketball players that have changed the game
let's take like Steph Curry most most recently uh that for him for him to be you know in the game
in that way of being unconscious of of slipping into the flow of the game changed the game yeah right
and so you say the the within the confines of the game but let's not pretend like the confines of the
game are stabilized beyond the least interesting version of like 94 feet by 34 yeah no no i i agree with
that i agree it's it's the sort of tactical dynamics of team play yeah i get that i agree with that right
yeah so you i mean again as long as you're creating a a non-individuator you can even talk about it in
terms of a person it just can't be simply individuated it's it can't simply be a personal
experience right right and it has to be i mean for the overman to make sense it has to be it has to
have some sense of overcoming the human right like it has to have that now that everything then depends
of course on how one determines the human and what one means by overcoming well so so what would it
mean because i mean you seem to be suggesting that it has to be a kind of collective transformation
in some way but what i i'm struggling because again i feel like i'm just i want to oversimplify
the concept and like turn it like when you catch fire in a basketball game you're somehow accessing
the overman like when traditionally you're you're the last man or you're embodying resentment most of
your life and then there's these moments when you catch fire you know and you're suddenly channeling
something extra human otherworldly whatever you know and that doesn't seem quite right like in the
in the way that it's articulated and again i am just following this i'm not committed to anything
that i'm that i'm saying but to say that Steph Curry changed the game of basketball isn't to say
That there is a person who has exerted a force or a will like Steph Curry changed the game of basketball
for Steph Curry as well, yeah, right, that you have to take Steph Curry as the kind of affective
introduction or the introduction of some antigen into the game of basketball that changed it and
Steph Curry the person that continues to play the game on any given night like think about the way that
he's transformed what the basketball human could be like imagine, you know, the epitome, like Shaq is one
of the best players of all time, could Shaq play in the contemporary, in contemporary NBA? And you know
the answer is probably yes. And you know, Shaq, Shaq because he's Shaq. I mean, but he didn't, he didn't
change the game though, he was an anomaly, right? You know, that's, that's a huge difference. Like he, yes
that's exactly right, he didn't change the game at all. He was just an unbelievably dominant force just
because of the size and skill. Yeah, back on the question of the zone, I mean I honestly
I don't know. I mean it just, it seems like such a foreign connection to me to think of it in terms of
to connect the kairos and the zone to the overman. Yeah, um, because I I guess maybe in part because I
always feel like the overman is a project, um, and it it only makes sense to me to think of it as a
project which is the overcoming of the human, right? And that again, that and that doesn't mean eradicating
the species Homo sapien, it means making that species function in a different way. But I I don't think
of that as zone. I think of that because because to me at its best being in the zone, yes it does, I mean
yes, Steph Curry did change the game. I mean, I I don't doubt that, but by and large there's no overcoming
of humanity. There there is there is um humanity at its most excellent and extraordinary but there's
no sort of basic, there's no alteration to most of the attributes that I would associate with the
human going on. I love it. It's it encourages it gives me hope. I mean it really like I mean I've said
that before, right? The thing I love about sports is those occasional moments where you see in a
pressure-packed situation most of us, myself included, drop in our performance. Some amazing people stay
the same, right? But then there's those like few of them that the Jordans that get better and I always
just find that uh I don't even know what the right it's just hopeful. Like when I when I witness that
I'm just like ah there is potential but for this species. So it's it's sort of more it's like an
enhancement of human capacity rather than a transformation of what it means to be a human
like at least if we're thinking in Heidegger's terms here he talks about a qualitative change
not a quantitative so in some ways I guess you know catching fire like Steph Curry does or like
Damian Lillard in that one playoff game where he just kept pushing them into overtime. I mean you're
watching something amazing but it's not like Damian transformed into something that was not human.
He was enhancing, you know, although I get what he did and I think there's something very interesting
in that. I mean I remember the one time in my life in an organized basketball game that that ever
happened for me and it was just it's so summed up by the Michael Jordan image when he you know
against the Pacers I believe it was, right? When he's when he's walking back and he does the to the to
the bench. Yeah, yeah, what did I do? Like, like I don't like I don't even know what's yeah that wasn't me
like I don't even I don't know what's going on and I remember that feeling of it doesn't matter. Like
I could throw the ball up and it's going in and I it's not me who's in charge of that. I think that
there is something conceptually very, you know, something interesting worth thinking about in those
moments. I don't feel like the the the project of the overman is is it doesn't immediately hook into
that for me but that's I mean that you can't do that right? Like I mean what may I would say like
to put it back into Heidegger's terminology a little bit what makes this concept strange to me
because Heidegger's obviously invested in it a lot is its relation to authenticity because yeah
to strip everything of what it means to be a human you would think would be some sort of inauthentic
relating but he wants to either come back to something or facilitate an engagement that is
in some way authentic but the overman how is that? I mean again it does it it can make sense for Heidegger
I just don't know how to articulate that right now like the relationship between I don't think that the
authenticity has anything to do with stability for Heidegger no right because I do think that there is an
auto-generating auto-transformative like relationship to aletheia I mean like it's not like something is
disclosed and then it stays that way like the state like the movement into disclosure is going to
create other disclosures and other you know I mean it's it's going to shut down redirect it's going to
incline you in in this or that direction and so it is a fundamentally transformative process and that's a weird
combination to think about authenticity as also self-transformative and not stabilizing and this
leads me i mean we don't i'm not like married to to having to continue to think about the relationship
between the zone, kairos, and um, and the overman, overman, but there is a way that there we have a tendency
of making moments of kairos too rare, right? it's like i'm in the zone i'm out of the zone it's like no i'm
always in a zone i just might not be in that zone or the zone that i want to, right? i'm always in a
zone i'm never hypostasized, right? hypostasizing itself is an activity of becoming that you know we
might call it an extreme slowing down but there is still movement and then so i think about something
like the overman as if it could have clear parameters like what would it be what could it
mean for the human not to be in the process of overcoming itself
yeah even and and what's interesting about returning it back to heidegger is it would seem like
the human's authentic relationship to itself would be of a maybe a style but a style of of overcoming
of the human well so that but that's where i mean and i think you probably just didn't get to that i
think it might be in lecture five but the last man the figure of the last man is for him basically
the human that has ceased overcoming himself right um which seems to be that the case for
niches like a sedentary yeah resentment relates to that a little bit too yeah like which is what
there's all these contradictions that are productive but they're just strange to me like
heidegger's invested in quietness and slowness but that quiet persistence of subjectivity is also the
target so it's like when you just move about your day and do the thing you know go to your job and all
that stuff that's bad in some way for heidegger because you're not accessing but i think one of the
things that i give him credit and i like this is you know and he uses the word tone there but you know
making the distinction like look all kinds of experiences have different tones and and so and
he takes that sentence you know his sentence of we're we are still not thinking and he begins with
like look that here there's an obvious tone in which one can hear that and it's the negative tone
everything sucks today and you know and and that's familiar and it's not that that's simply absent but
he's after a different tone in that which is we are almost there we are getting close we are on the
way so this sort of positive or hopeful tone that's both of them are available in the sentence so the
problem of course is thinking that the sentence just means something and and that what you need to do
is for him and that's the slowness you need to patiently attend to the different tones available
in this and and that's what he's doing via lecturing is trying to get you to hear the tone and i think
it's the same thing for the overman is that like look there's a tone to humanity that's a it's available
there um that is the overcoming of itself it's just kind of uh overshadowed by a different kind of tone
which is representational thinking technological uh way ways of living um so my guess is i mean
this is back to the the kind of therapy coming like you know heidegger's vision of this future of this
imaginable future world and i give him credit for this is just to inject a little more slowness
and a little more his word would be care right like in for being in time would be a little carefulness
care care in relation to the thinking and i love that right like i mean i'm i'm i'm totally on board
with that in that in that tone you know it's it's like that's what he's doing and that's what that's
what i got from it when i read it is again whatever the claims are about this or that um are less
important than the reading of heidegger i mean i know i say that shit all the time and i know it's
it it just becomes banal but and it it seems like sometimes i mean at least in the in the mode of
teaching or of pedagogy it's like finding the not the appropriate tone but finding a tone that works
that will you know allow people to engage or that forces people to use heidegger's word that what's the
tone that will involve my students right so the quiet tone can sometimes be effective and can
create a storm of thinking or the the you know he talks about Nietzsche screaming even though it's
kind of a quiet sentence you know the wasteland grows he's like Nietzsche screamed that sentence
to allow for the quietness of thinking through you know the the conceptual work so it's like yeah
but i like that i mean i i like that now now for instance where it goes and for heidegger in terms
of poetry as being a more um i don't know authentic relation to language than other i mean i i don't
think it has to go there in fact i go quite the opposite which is like look at all the poetry in
everyday conversation or if you have to call it poetry I'd rather not, like, look, you know, simply say
there are different tones available in language of all kind, um, and and that to me is, yeah, so what?
The project, or what my project, and quite honestly like I, you know, one of the things that um that
happened to me in the course of reading the Heidegger last night and realizing, first of all, how difficult
it was and truly like physically painful, like I don't want to be doing this, it's angering me, it's not
getting me out of my anger, it's frustrating me even more, but that it transitioned, right, and I got hooked
in and I was like one of the big thoughts for me that just popped into my head that I kept
returning to was this is why I want to write is because it can do that, right? Um, not that it always
does do that and certainly not that it's going to do that for everyone but like, you know, to the extent
that I feel truly thankful to live in a world in which Nietzsche and Derrida and Deleuze wrote
like I'm truly thankful, like that has made my life better, yeah, then then I need to do that, right, and
and put it out there and again it doesn't I'm not saying everyone's going to read this thing but that's
something that it can do, right, and and that's something that Heidegger did if Heidegger does nothing
else other than do what it did for me last night reading it was worth it, yeah, reading Heidegger, yeah, you know
and that's a value, right? Like that's introducing a tone, a new time. I don't know if it's new or not;
it doesn't matter if it's new or not, introducing a different tone into a system that's doing this
like frazzled, frantic thing, yeah, and that allows it to, you know, I don't want to start using words
like harmonious because I'm going to start sounding new agey as well, but it, you know, produces a shift
in that that enabled me to just sort of like calm the fuck down and right right that's an incredibly
productive. Oh yeah, you know, and I know it's not it doesn't do that for everyone, and I know there
are times where I've read Heidegger where all it did was infuriate me, you know, and well even if the
conceptual just real quick that even if the conceptual work is ambiguous and difficult, you are locating
yourself in that ambiguity so it's still that's right the therapeutics of like finding the thread
and like you find Nietzsche in those couple passages and then you lose him and then Heidegger talks about
like that dialectic or whatever, the importance of finding somebody and then losing them and then
finding them but yeah which that it made me think of you when I read that particular passage when he's
like okay in order when he gets to the point of like finding Nietzsche we need to lose him and I'm like
that is just straight up right like that's not even subtly Hegelian yeah yeah yeah it's just overtly
Hegelian, not that everything's not Hegelian but some of the things just really strike me at times and
for instance the the being face to face with the tree uh that reminded me of um Hegel's bit on the tree
in the house and the generic implementation of like universal concepts and yeah it really did but see
and and the problem with that of course and like I I get it I get I get the distinction that he's after
which is the there are different ways of facing a tree yeah right some of which seem more um full
and some of which are more instrumental right like I I get that that makes sense and and I think those
distinctions matter and I think we don't have a good vocabulary for talking about those styles or
comportments or dispositions but then and you haven't gotten to this yet I don't know if you did or
not made but um then he's like well dogs can't you know um be face to face no I did read they I was
like well why yeah why not right like dogs can't have a face because they don't have the ratio and
they don't have language right right and it's like they can be snout to snout they can still orient
to a tree like why not yeah I know and and also just like what extraordinary I mean because he lays
out that chain of being thing and I thought what he was going to do was this very classical I thought
he was going to do this kind of very classical move of saying you know humans aren't don't have any
particular they're indeterminate which was the claim he takes from Nietzsche yeah because they don't
have any particular essence that to me is that's that's the kind of conventional claim of humanism you
know is that there's no necessary essence to humans however they are on this chain of being and and that
chain goes from the physical to the spiritual and the further you move up by using reason the better
off you are that's the humanist mantra but there's no necessary location of the human we just have the
potential to be gods right and I thought he was going to problematize that and he fucking didn't
like he really just kind of bought the chain of being thing of the ratio and its relationship to
phusis like we are metaphysical you know we are the physical that aspires to go beyond the physical
Right, and which is not saying, I mean, we're the being that thinks it's being, that that's right, I mean.
It is totally, yeah, so, so, that, that, that's the place where I start going, all right, granddad, yeah, yeah, you know.
There, there's a point where you, you've just gone a little too far into, you know, you're racist.
Besides, yeah, you know, your animal hatred, there's no animal studies in these few lectures, I don't think.
The privileging and centrality of the human, it's like, you know, there, there's a way in which, and again.
It's, I understand that it's historical, and you know, at a substantial level this doesn't matter all that.
Much, but he just does seem tied to to this notion of the the sort of, I don't know, the the privilege and.
Importance of his version, yeah, of non-presence being the attribute he did, and again to me, to me though.
When he, when he kind of gives the definition of the metaphysical, metaphysical, and he goes through the.
Sensual and the the conceptual, and then this is how we kind of achieve uh this state of being, it did.
Feel like there was some inherent contradictions there, like he he seemed to be pointing out the.
Arbitrary arbitrarity arbitrariness what is the word of of those distinctions, right? I mean because like.
It's like we've emplaced that definition, right? So he does seem to at least point to the performative.
Instantiation of the metaphysical rather than like just that is what we are, you know, and so but it.
Just buys, I mean, there's a totally different, I mean, take the Deleuze to what I would call the Deleuze.
Tack of multiplicity into that problem, and rather than sort of like, hey, we need to push the human.
Further, be like, what the fuck is human? Yeah, like there's that has never, like, we have never been that.
And and so that that category itself is the thing, so that's like imploding it rather than, you know.
Moving beyond it.
Well, because I'm thinking about the paradigmatic example for Nietzsche, which is Christianity.
Christianity is the hatred of life, right? Period, right? And like, and in there are some ways you just.
Want to be like, it's not even the the the introduction of an arbitrary set of norms for what counts of life.
Is it's like Christian theology sort of like condemns this life for the sake of a non-life, an afterlife that's pretty.
Motherfucking life deprecating, but you know, you would have to, you know, you'd have to allow for the possibility of saying.
It's not the only life, and this other life in the clouds looks pretty cozy to me, so like here's one mode of life.
Hate life, so I can have another life, well or it just yeah, and it produces ways of being in the world, right?
Like so I mean Christians live in certain kind of ways, obviously it's multiple and diffuse but.
So the the belief in an afterlife and the that even if you accept Nietzsche's diagnosis as as life.
Deprecating, it's still a mode of life, and he will say like in his better moments he'll say.
Say what you want, it's still will to power, right? It is still, it is, and and that's where you just say.
Look, it's that's where multiplicity becomes crucial to me is you have different modes of life who walk.
Around living in different ways, some of which some people would call life deprecating, others of which.
They would call life enhancing, and there isn't a governing answer, there is simply like we can't get.
Outside of that problem to say is that really life deprecating or is it really life affirming, you know, it's.
Like no, I mean the the belief in an afterlife produces ways of acting in the world um which.
Sort of like forces you to be in a position where like yeah like what happens when I like spicy food.
Isn't just an assertion a reflection of my own personal taste that I can never push on someone but.
It's worth me pushing, yeah, like it's worth it, but it's worth like you're you're saying that, you know.
A certain orientation to Covid is worth pushing on other people, right? Despite the fact that there.
Isn't a transcendent, like you don't get to feel right or justified in it, but you're still going.
To push for it, right? That's exactly right, like it doesn't have to be you don't have to have that.
Meta top down, you can say, look I can see what the result of your approach to Covid is and it's that.
People get sick and die, yeah, and and my that doesn't get but that doesn't give like the fact.
That look my approach to Covid is far less likely to make people get sick and die and yours isn't.
But that then doesn't give me license to some kind of uh self-righteousness to I don't have a.
Transcendent, yeah, I don't have a transcendent position, I am working but doesn't take away but.
Doesn't take away the capacity to attack, that's exactly right, it doesn't, I'm not justified in.
This, I'm not licensed it but motherfucker I'm still coming after to you so now you see okay here.
That point is I think one that analytic the the types that call themselves analytic philosophers can.
Never hear, which is there is in other words what you're saying is there is no ground and there does
Not need to be for action, right? Right there just doesn't need to be. It's unnecessary, and so the desire
to find a ground again, that's one kind of life, right? It's like that I must have a basis for my
morality, utilitarianism, deontological, whatever it may be, right? I must have some sort of basis, like
no, you don't. You don't have to do that's why I've always said like how does Nietzsche substantiate
his truth claims? He says them, right? Yeah, well and like look substantiating, uh, basing, grounding
right, you know, they're not really grounded, they're not really substantiated, they're not really
performatively enacted, but they're you have the performatively enacted that are going to gain
traction with certain kinds of modes of thinking and are going to create resistances to other modes
of thinking too, right? That's right. That that that's why performativity is crucial, right? Like a performativity
can get you away from logic, logic as a necessary basis, because you say logic would itself be
performatively instantiated. There doesn't have to be activity pulls logic up to its level rather
that's right. And the other the other aspect of this problematic that I'm thinking of right now is that
like complexity of deconstruction or whatever of these of these philosophical systems does not
necessitate nihilism or inactivity, which is kind of a common accusation that like if you really think
through all this and if there is no ground to reality or being then it's going to lead to well
anything goes, you know, and that's not the case. I mean absolutely think of Hegel and Derrida specifically
I mean they were very politically active and they made decisions so it doesn't preclude the possibility
of making concrete decisions but let's even let's even I'd even go further than that look at the history
of humanity none of the decisions and none of the actions have actually had grounds that weren't
simply performatively produced, right? And yet we've done a whole lot of shit and encourage certain
behaviors and discouraged other behaviors, right? So we don't have to have the basis in a god. What we have
to have is the claim to a basis in a god, right? The performative, performative, you need the performative
right? Yeah, that that that subject doesn't have to pre-exist, it is retroactively installed as pre-existing
right? And maybe I mean would the argument be that most people need the figure of a ground
well you hypostasize it, right? Like you hypostasize and you say well if it's retroactively installed as
pre-existing this is Lacan on the real by the way, right? Like the retroactive installation of its
pre-existence is exactly that kind of logic. And yeah, like um in order to have force in order to be
persuasive people need, you know, humans and this is a characteristic of humanity, they need to believe
that it comes from somewhere that's not another person, right? If it's simply another person's like
right I claim this then that is what's called doxa or opinion or whatever we need caddy on here yeah
we do. I mean but at point because like at least in the in the 70s and and you know the reception of
Derrida and then today even you you find that the dangers, you know, people the accusations of the dangers
of deconstruction never made any sense to me. I mean it doesn't make any sense. The idea that we're
getting rid of values because there's no because there is no ontological basis in God or in reason
or logic because those things don't function as bases that suddenly anything goes and there's no it's
like no that's never been the case, right? And I mean it that's where it just doesn't make the the claim
of that version of nihilism attributed to so-called post-modernity is just right right it's so logic
based. Like in order to make that claim you have to you have to believe there has to be a suprasensory
basis, yeah, for everything in order for anything to exist. No it doesn't yeah why which means everything
has to be the correct or the incorrect, the better or the worse, the closer to the logically, you know,
justifiable or further away from it. I mean well if you just take a sheerly sociological version
you know, of humanity, you don't need any of those things you just need the claim to those things
yeah, right? And the repetition of the claim and the habituation of practices associated with the claim
right? Like all of those things I mean I I firmly believe like if you could get 10,000 Americans to
believe you know just pick anything that like owls are saviors you know I just I just whatever um like
and you get their you get their families to reproduce that for five generations there will be an owl
religion in a in a thousand years that's you know and it's that it's that simple sociologically now
again it can't seem necessarily that arbitrary but the things that people believe today in terms of for
instance Christianity they are 100 a result of a historical accretion of the repetition of practices
of I promise you something some dumb ass folks concocted at some point to be like hey I know how
We can get people to do shit, let's tell them it's God, right? Right? Though, I mean, you know, it's that move.
To say, like, look, the, you know, truths are made or or practices are habituated, and I actually I really like
that lying in Heidegger's like, what are you talking about, like habituation without a notion of or a
habit without a notion of habituation, right? Like habits are, you know, always habituated. But anyway
you know, habits have to be, you know, we can't, it's very, it's too easy to isolate a habit in and of
itself, like the repetition of, you know, take Nietzsche's example in Truth and Lies, the repetition of leaf leaf leaf leaf leaf
right? And there are there are reasons why leaf guy, you know, repeated and habituated in ways that other
possible other possibilities didn't, and it's not because leaf is truer in a transcendent way, but because
it has different points of contact with existing other habituations, and so, you know, like there is a
there is a field of habituations that make the emergence of some new, you know, things more or less likely, and you know, puts
i will save your religion on the less likely than on the more likely not because it has anything to do with
it's, you know, it's correspondence with the transcendent truth, with its truth, right? Right? Yeah. So, but I mean, you know, what
follows from that is an incredible I mean, I don't know, like an incredible freedom on the one hand, right
which is like, hey, there's no basis other than history and sociology for anything, you know, um, and
but also an incredible terror, right? For I think a lot of people of like, wait, you're saying they're really
like, I mean, this is the Nietzsche assassin creed moment, you know, nothing is true, everything is permitted.
It really is everything really is permitted. It just doesn't, that doesn't mean there won't be consequences
yeah, for things that you do, right? Um, but everything everything you do right like, but but everything is
permitted. There is no larger than life base, you know, other than sociological basis for anything.
Yeah, you know, but I do think, I mean, and Nietzsche says this as well, like the perpetual performative
enactment of a ground to reality does it's like a sedative, you know, for the the general population
and I think to a certain extent, like having someone like Trump in office, you know, who could be thought
of as like the Naked Lunch, you know, he kind of exposes the the the cracks in the system does lead to
chaos. I mean, it's chaotic, right? Because people need like we because we we had said for even though it was a
lie, we'd said for years democracy democracy president stability, all these things, and then all of a sudden
every average Joe has access to a panoply of conspiracy theories that lead to non-faith in the government
in any sense of reality. I mean, I think it is dangerous at least on a like a practical level, right? For just for
for the whole population to have some sort of just kind of vague herd, right? For the herd, I was I was
gonna say, well, it's dangerous for us as we're living now in this moment, right? Right? Like it is
yeah, it's it's created dangerous now that matters. I mean, like in other words, I want social stability
right? Right? And I want it because it enables all kinds enables lets me do whatever I want to do
yeah, live my life, right? You know, play basketball, teach, but there's no but there's but it's not
because I'm not it's not because I'm right about the desire for social stability, it's because that's
the thing that I want because it's a selfish desire. Yeah, well it doesn't it needn't even be selfish
like it could be like, hey, it's better for more people. Like I could make some kind of utilitarian
argument. It doesn't have to be selfish, but the basis is a social basis. It can't be anything but
that. Yeah, and so it can't be because I'm right because I'm it's not that because for instance you
could make one could make a potentially interesting argument which is this sort of because I think that
a lot of what's what drives these folks really is a desire to burn everything down, right? Like that
that's it's just like anything that looks like structure and stability needs to get burned down
well man there's a way of seeing that as an incredibly inventive exercise so that you could
say like actually the kind of Trump inspired movement of angry stupidity that is filtering
could be the absolute best thing for the emergence of the overman, right? Right? Like there's an argument
and that makes sense. That's imaginable, right? That's imaginable as a possible eventuality to me or
creating the baseline conditions for a new and higher and better form of life than humanity
as we kill ourselves. That's imaginable to me, yeah, right? Um, it's just not one that I want to participate
in. Yeah, as a living being at this time I'd like to I'd like to delay that anarchy a little bit
you know, I don't know, I like my comfort, you know, give it another 70 years and there's like a different
question. I mean, you guys can go ahead and do that fucking thing, but I mean and that's the problem is
that there's always people, you know, along that scale who like don't want that thing so they want the
structure and stability so we want the Jeffrey Bezos right like we were as a symptom of a certain kind
and so we want that and and and and again like the question is not um which one is better for humanity
which one is more life-affirming is an is an impossible and this is Nietzsche it's an impossible
question to ask as a participant in life like you you can't get outside of being a participant in life
and say which what's better for the species
you